e
e e
[Music]
good evening everybody um I wish to
convene the uh finance committee for
Monday May 20th 2024
the first item of resolution is
temporary resolution
6124 a resolution to appropriate from
the unincumbered balance and amend
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor and the police and fire
Levy fund
247 and uh Mr is uh thank you chair
wolfinger uh you know once again this
will be coming from the Safety Committee
I know this is something we've discussed
uh quite extensively in our committee uh
I know we have council member team being
my second but not to steal any Thunder
from assistant chief Schultz I'll turn
it over to you sir uh thank you member
of the council this legislation is um to
fund a purchase of the property of
joining engal 3 um we look at it as an
opportunity um in the future there would
be an expansion or any type of
construction we need to do um we'd have
the property on hand um and this does
come from unencumbered money in our own
budget already and if there's any
questions and and this is also if I
remember correctly uh from the chief
this is also to uh hopefully offset the
rebuilding if you will of a fire station
three right this will address that
future concern as I understand it yes it
could be uh we're working towards
putting a maintenance building in the
back which kind of started the dialogue
between the next the nearby Property
Owners um but it is a a very good
location and in the future having a
wider footprint and more options um as
we would build a modern Firehouse would
definitely be beneficial to the citizens
yeah no I just want to commend the admin
ation of the fire department as well as
administration of the city for having
that foresight so thank you very much
for your work on that welcome thank you
very much any other
questions and who will be your second uh
council member tener thank you and three
read three readings yes sir thank you
thank you Mr chair next item is
temporary resolution
6224 a resolution to change the special
Revenue fund 2060 timbertop Tiff to a
capital project fund
3060 coming from finance
committee um do you want to really talk
yeah this one is where um last year I
attempted to do my due diligence with
the state auditor's office and ask what
fund said it should be special Revenue
capital projects fund um last May and
they emailed back that said it's a
special Revenue fund did all my due
diligence last year and as I'm getting
ready and getting set after the first
Tiff settlement going through then they
gave me oh here's an auditor State
bullet it says it needs to be a capital
projects
fund so I never kind of one step forward
two steps back so I'm just doing
legislation to allow the change from a
two special Revenue to a three so we can
cover the basis and move
forward very good any questions kind of
a housekeeping item we're looking to
suspend second and third reading if you
would would not mind that would be any
objections from
Council um uh Larry would you do the
second on that please thank you those
are only two resolutions today now
ordinances uh temporary ordinance
18-24 an ordinance to authorize the
mayor to enter enter into an agreement
to purchase 1590 East Main Street
approximately 1.0 plus or minus Acres of
real property further identified as
Fairfield County auditor parcel number
86100 for an amount not to exceed
$250,000 and to declare an emergency and
that's uh again coming from the Safety
Committee uh yes thank you Mr uh Mr
chair uh once again council member aers
will be my second on this legislation
and this legislation is um tied to the
earlier legislation we talked about
temporary resolution there um once again
this is just allowing the sale allowing
the mayor to enter an agreement like it
says in the heading there to purchase
the property so the previous legislation
allows for a moving of funds this
legislation allows the actual purchasing
of the property so very good uh I know I
didn't ask you
before um we've had this discussion in
Council quite a bit is there any
emergency or any need
to suspend third reading or anything
like that closing set or not or no I I
double check checked with uh Chief mafin
uh three readings are good for both
pieces of legislation but thank you Mr
chair thank
you any questions comments thank you and
we also have temporary ordinance
19-24 an ordinance to repeal and replace
Langster codified ordinance part s
business Regulation Code chapter 709
cultivation processing or dispensing of
medical marijuana of the codified
ordinance of the city of Lancaster and
this is coming from the law committee
yes uh thank you Mr wolfinger I would
like to open this up to the law
director thank you sir so um everybody's
aware that uh ballot initiative to
passed in November of 2023 which
legalized uh adult use cannabis which is
the state term for recreational
marijuana essentially um and we have
until about September um September 7th
of 2024 in order to put a moratorium in
place uh pursuant to that language the
language in the new 3780 which is the
Cannabis control section of the higher
Revised Code um I had spoken with
several Community leaders um judges the
County prosecutor law enforcement agents
Etc um who all indicated that they did
not think it would be beneficial um for
the city of L lter to allow adult use
cannabis dispensaries um cultivators or
processors within the city limits and
city council had already banned medical
marijuana dispensaries cultivators and
processors within the city limits um and
so I am putting forward a uh piece of
legislation in order to amend our
codified ordinance that addresses
medical marijuana to add adult use
cannabis to that ordinance um law
committee yourself and included um spoke
about this at our last meeting May 5th I
believe um and indicated that it was
something that you would like to see
proceed so this is I think the cleanest
um route to do that and again I'll just
remind everybody this is in the business
regulation section this is not in the
general offenses section so this does
not speak to personal marijuana
possession Andor you know growth
Etc those are still technically illegal
by the way but um once they are legal we
will have to look at changing the rest
of the codified ordinance in order to
make it match thank you lator you're
very welcome and your second will be me
yep and you're looking at three readings
yes any questions
comments thank you that uh the only two
ordinances we have now we'll move on to
uh other discussion items departmental
updates
thank you members of council I'll be
brief uh we have a presentation in a
regular council meeting so I just had a
couple of things we had a promotion
ceremony today four of our officers were
promoted to Sergeant uh very excited
about that especially to backfill those
positions on patrol that was we were in
dire need of that and we had a sergeant
promoted to Lieutenant so we'll have a
new Patrol Commander what that does is
open opens up the uh ranks to our
training Sergeant position
which is the first time ever and uh I
think that given the value of training
and seeing the results we've had from
Advanced Training and putting a priority
on training that'll be awesome for our
department they'll continue to go out
there and and handle these calls like
the experts that they are so we're
really excited about that uh the second
one is uh I gave Mrs tener um some
envelopes those are invitations to our
award ceremony on May
30th again not a requirement but it
would be awesome if anyone could attend
because I think um it will really open
up your eyes to to what the men and
women do at that department we're giv
out I think five or six life-saving
Awards which is pretty tremendous uh and
all of those stories are really really
good to hear as well as Randy Barto
Awards which is exemplary Service as
well and I think you'll see that a lot
of the decisions made here on the
council floor directly reflected in some
of those Awards uh the patrol Shields
the less lethal shotgun guns the even
just the ability to hire a good
candidate as opposed to hiring somebody
with an opata certificate that is
something that the department will fail
if we get rid of um we we can never
resort to just hiring only opata
certified candidates the fact that you
allow me to to look at somebody in the
eye and see that they're a good person
and hire them and train them later is
exactly why we are where we are today so
uh would love to have you guys it's one
of those things you can walk in dinner's
on on the LCPA um there's a social event
after you can walk out you're you're not
obligated to anything um but would love
to have you there for
sure thank
you good evening Council just a quick
update um the
2024 Street Improvement programs moving
right along we have completed the
milling and filling of all the streets
on the list this year so the paving
portion of the Project's done um all we
have left to do is we need to uh seal
the joints where old payment meets new
payment or new payment meets curbs that
kind of stuff and we need to adjust
castings and valve boxes to grade put
the concrete rings around them and then
uh follow up with some striping here
later uh towards the middle of July and
then uh uh once that's done we'll do a
final walk through and generate a punch
list to see what little things uh we
missed that need to be corrected before
we accept it but we're on schedule even
though with all the rain we've had
they've managed to keep up with things
and we're on target to finish Late July
so that's where we are on that one
question how did the the budget come
with what you've allocated for Paving
what you had to pay for Paving any extra
opportunities we're we're we're under
budget right now for the Sip projects
we've actually been able to if you've
noticed over in front of the new parks
office Fifth Avenue the water department
replaced a water line from slum to
Washington and with their um trench they
needed to repair that for our standards
which basically they had to do half the
street so we combined with them to do
the other half so we put some money
together and we repay from Curb to curb
that section of Fifth Avenue from SLO
clear to to um Washington so and on the
radar is the same thing going to happen
on Franklin where the water department
replac the water line from Fair Avenue C
down to 6th Avenue so once uh the Water
Department gets ready to do their half
we'll jump in there with the same
contractor and and get the other half
done that's one less Street we'll have
to put on this projects moving forward
and uh that'll be a big help we're
getting ready to um lay a leveling
course inous on Sheridan Drive from
Rainbow to the Corp line up in the north
end where the Beverly Hills addition to
the west of uh Sheran Drive has been
taken care of with the full full dep M
Millan and filling we're going to
microsurface the east side of the road
streets uh that's going to include um
Sher and drive from the Corp from the
Corp to Rainbow but we're actually going
to do a cape seal on that which is going
to be a leveling course with a chip seal
course followed by the micro um the base
of that road is in good shape um there's
no need to spend a bunch of money
Milling it up and putting down new
asphalt when it really doesn't need it
so we're going to dress it up get some
some things fixed and U that road will
last us a lot longer than than we
anticipated to very good thank you any
other questions is there a plan to uh
address the condition of Arbor Valley
Drive before the new new high school
opens up it's it's being scheduled for
around for right after right after the
school opens um we're looking at
combining some different types of
funding to get Arbor Valley done all the
way from Farah Avenue to um
37 um right now we don't want to jump in
there and do a whole lot because they're
going to run construction traffic on it
for another couple years but uh that is
on the radar also for some STP funding
some some sip money funding and any
other funding we can kind of find cuz
it's going to we're going to widen it
we're going to do away with some of the
sidewalks on the one side since we have
the bike trail on the east side um so
we're going to take advantage of of some
of that to actually make it usable for
football traffic and and allow parking
on both sides so we don't have all the
wild parallel parking off up in the
weeds in people's yards during football
games so um and we're
re according to the plans right now
they're they're going to take that
Island out of Arbor Valley Drive that's
in front of the high school now so uh
once they get those the old building
tore down get those parking lots started
that's when uh we'll do that realignment
there because it actually doesn't really
lay within the rideway so we're going to
try to straighten it out and actually
put the road in the rideway where it's
supposed to be thank you that's coming
up very good thank you any other
questions comments thank
you any other departmental
updates running out of
people okay uh tonight's meeting prep
president Porter thank you council
member wolfinger tonight we have a
followup uh with City storm water um in
relation to additional background
information for temporary ordinance
1524 we also have an InFocus
departmental presentation which is the
city police department
uh would like to thank uh service safety
director Woody for uh facilitating our
in Focus uh presentations with our city
departments um it's really an
opportunity for our city departments to
come talk to us and tell us what's going
on um and we're going to try to keep
those as interesting as possible for
folks so thank you that's all thank you
uh other items for finance
committee hearing none I'm looking for a
motion to ajour so moved
second thank
you uh roll call uh Mr alss yes Mr alers
yes Mr skover yes and me yes we are
adjourned and it is
616 Lancaster City council meeting will
convene promptly at 6:30
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home in
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
74653 652
stop in and see us at either of our two
locations 405 North Columbus Street in
Lancaster and 207 South Main Street in
Baltimore respect for tradition regard
for
[Music]
change hi this is jolen Pew with Big
Brothers Big Sisters of South Eastern
Ohio for well over 100 years Big
Brothers Big Sisters have operated under
the belief that every child can succeed
and thrive in life this month we have
once again been chosen as the recipient
of the Buckeye cares program that means
that Buckeye cares will make a generous
donation with every vehicle they sell in
the month of May thank you Buckeye for
helping out our kids and support of your
local community
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
please rise and join me in a moment of
prayer God grant us the serenity to
accept the things we cannot change the
courage to change the things we can and
the wisdom to know the difference thank
thank
you Lancaster City Council for May 20th
2024 has been convened please join me in
the Pledge of Allegiance I pledge
aliance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all please call the role m Mr aers here
Mr ALS here Mr bisj here Mrs hoop here
Mr lenberg here Mr niser here Mr skover
here miss tener here Mr Wing here Mr
wolfinger
here please let the record reflect that
all 10 members of Lancaster City Council
are present reading and disposing of the
journal regular meeting minutes dated
May 6
2024 Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and follow Journal
second we have a motion a second to read
U read and dispose of the journal all
those in favor please say I I all those
oppos same sign reports of City
officials series of emails dated May 6
2024 regarding law committee minutes
submitted by Mr niser email dated May 6
2024 regarding finance committee minutes
submitted by Mr wolfinger email dated
May 8th 2024 regarding the May in Focus
presentation before coun Council
submitted by service safety director
Carrie Woody email dated May 8th 2024
regarding the 2024 April income tax
collections submitted by Tax
Commissioner Amy Hamilton email dated
May 15th 2024 regarding code and zoning
committee minutes submitted by Mr aers
email dated May 16th 2024 regarding an
appointment to the Fairfield County
Regional Planning Commission submitted
by mayor McDaniel email dated May 16th
2024 regarding an email from attorney
David Hodge referencing the Sheridan
Shaw property an ation submitted by law
director Hall email dated May 17th 2024
regarding the finance committee agenda
submitted by Mr
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to receive and file the reports
of City officials second have motion and
second to receive and file the reports
of City officials all those in favor
please say I I all those oppos same
sign Communications email dated May 8th
20124 regarding a request for
information submitted by Rick Romanowski
email dated May 9th 2024 ing permanent
ordinance 14-24 submitted by attorney
Brian
Everett Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the
communications second we have a motion a
second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
say I I all those oppos same sign we now
move on to special presentation and
awards and joining us this even evening
in followup to their previous
presentation is the city storm water
department
all right good evening city
council you got it did I yeah
all right looks like we got it all right
thanks again for allowing me time
tonight to present um so as I think you
all know the previous city council
meeting I gave a presentation um related
to the rate increase ordinance for the
storm water utility uh and I know one of
the comments that was um provided was uh
you I didn't really touch on any
background of utility and the the work
we've been able to do improvements we've
made throughout the city these past
couple decades since the utility was
started so wanted to take o opportunity
tonight to touch on some of that and
again hopefully show you the good work
we've been able to do with the the funds
we've collected over the years so start
with a brief bit of background uh so
again as touched on last time uh the
storm water utility program was created
in 2003 and there were four primary
issues that took place or that occurred
in the late 1990s early 2000s that led
to the creation of the storm water
utility uh first there is on South Broad
Street there's a large Dage storm sewer
there were multiple collapses in the
late '90s that required the city to
borrow about a million dollars for
repair and placement of that line um the
other one
other or one other issue that occurred
is that um the long-term control plan
that we had as the city which addresses
combined sewer overflows um pinpointed
this Lake Allen Maple sewer separation
project that was
necessary uh and the need to fund that
on the storm water side uh to the degree
of about $2 million is what was
estimated at the time so uh again um you
know that big dollar amount is is
something determined that um you know
might be nice to have utility to raise
funds to put towards that uh another
item here was the oepa finalizing their
Phase 2 Municipal separate storm sewer
system permit the ms4 permit is what
it's known for known under by short or
or known as uh and um the uh city of
Lancaster was going to be covered by
that and again having a mechanism in
place uh with which we could use to um
to comply with the requirements of those
permits again it was deemed a good good
reason to have utility and then the
final reason there around that time
there was a decrease in general fund
monies provided to lot who and they
still do the um storm water maintenance
for the city on on behalf of the storm
water department uh but back in the day
um again with the decrease in funds uh
and the ability um or trying to wean off
the general fund fund to cover the costs
that that they incurred in that again
was deemed made sense to have utility
for that uh so upon the creation in 2003
of the storm water utility we were given
the following directives from city
council first they wanted us to comply
with the requirements of the ms4 permit
and compliance issues related to the
city's long-term control plan second
they wanted reduced Reliance uh in fact
there's no Reliance currently on the
general fund for storm water activities
another directive was that they wanted
us to maximize the use of funds
throughout grants or through grants and
related programs and then finally work
within the existing Department framework
to eliminate overhead costs uh so we've
been uh you know these past 20 years
trying to to keep those items in mind
and and um run the program uh with those
those directives in
mind so looking into storm water
projects so uh since 2003 when we
created um the fees that have been
collected have been used to undertake a
variety of storm water improvements a
lot of people when they think storm
water improvements they're thinking you
know catch basins manholes uh storm pipe
in the ground and yeah that's part of it
but there's kind of a broader scope of
improvements we do utilize or do create
with the funds we have so again you know
storm Sue repairs Replacements
expansions obviously making repairs and
Replacements uh of the existing system
that's in place many of which is 80 90
or even 100 years old uh and then trying
to expand storm sewers into areas where
we don't currently have it where uh it
would be a benefit to have it is is
something we've used utilized with the
funds Culver repairs and replacement
ments just making sure um we repairing
any failed coverts over the years and
then doing preventive maintenance and
replacing the old aging coverts that are
in poor condition uh curb is an
important part of the storm water system
too so we try to do repairs Replacements
and again expansions of curb where we
can so that we're keeping that uh storm
water in the street funneled to the
basins and and out of people's yards
ideally uh cured in place pipelining or
CIP is a a more recent technology we've
been making use of again this is just a
a reh method um that we can use to
repair existing storm sewers without
needing to dig them up it goes much
faster you don't have as much of the um
headaches for pedestrians drivers and
whatnot having having those big uh
longtime consuming open trench projects
uh and then on the bottom there you know
in addition to that infrastructure we
put in we're also doing things like
stream Restorations which is improving
water quality in the Stream it's helping
um mitigate erosion uh issues that
happen to U property owners that have uh
that that reside uh next to the streams
where these Restorations are occurring
we're also creating wetlands in the city
um areas again uh where we can uh
increase water quality and um and then
finally flood control facilities uh in
conjunction with two Wetlands
specifically we created we have uh flood
control facilities along the hacking
River when obviously stream Rises uh
these areas allow the stream to overflow
into those areas and flood those areas
opposed to flood flooding residents in
the city um so those are a nice benefit
to the um to the city with the funds
we've been able to um make use of so
here um there's a lot on here I know but
the the general point I reason I
included this slide is just to show
these are all the lists uh and this
isn't I wouldn't say necessarily 100% um
U of all of everything we've done but a
vast vast majority is um represented
here there's 61 projects or 61
improvements we've been able to do
since the utility started about 20 years
ago averaging three per year about uh so
again this just shows kind of the
breadth of what we've been able to do
with the funds we've collected over the
years um there are six in particular I
wanted to highlight that I felt uh had
had a good um good benefit and to the
citizens and again showed some of the
things we can do with with the funds
that are raised through the storm water
utility uh the first one here is the Hub
restrain Improvement project so this
project uh came about around around the
time um the utility was started in the
early 2000s uh so this project and it's
been multiphased over the years but
essentially this project involved the
construction of a new pump station uh
down in the Hubert Reese area on the
south side of town off Broad Street and
uh We've installed over 2500 ft of new
storm sewers with the intent of
mitigating flooding uh in the residences
uh there along Lewis B and Hubert um and
I I will note um you know this area
isn't a flood plane uh some of the Yards
do sit low in the streets so you know
certainly these improvements uh did not
eliminate all issues but they have
heavily mitigated them and and we've
noticed uh the difference you know over
the years in recent years combined to to
to the complaints we got 15 20 years ago
it's a big difference so this was a a
good use of funds $1.1 million was spent
here uh and about 180,000 came from
storm water uh most of that was covered
by the general fund of the time because
again these issues arose uh around the
time and just before the utility was
created it um next project I wanted to
highlight was the lake Allen Maple sewer
separation project this was a very large
project uh storm water department teamed
with the Water Pollution Control
Department to construct over 10,000 ft
of new sanitary sewer over 4,200 feet of
new storm sewer and we CIP lined uh a
very large diameter combined sewer I
think it's a 60 in uh over 4,100 ft and
the primary reason uh or the the primary
impetus for that project was to reduce
CSO
and then also mitigate Street flooding
and basement backup issues that a lot of
the residents in the the Lake Street
Allen Street North Maple Street area
were experiencing due to being on that
CSO so having the sewer separate storm
sewers put in we were able to keep that
storm water out of the sanitary sewer
and again try to mitigate some of those
issues and again we've seen a lot of a
lot of differences in complaint uh
volumes up in that area as well that
project ran almost 9 million and almost
2 million of that came from storm water
funds uh the rest was covered by water
pollution Control Department for their
sanitary improvements next one here the
hacking River mul Wetlands so this is
one of the this was kind of a dual
purpose again this is a wetland
construction good for water quality but
this is one of the flood control
facilities I was referencing earlier
this is you know as the name implies
located right behind River Valley Mall
um it was a borrow area that they used
when they constructing the mall it was
it was just kind of ugly looking and and
wasn't really used for anything we
acquired that property and and was able
to construct this Wetland facility I
think there are four different cells
there all connected uh and again there's
um there's connections to the Hawking
River where if the Hawking River Rises
coming from Upstream uh Northwest of
town uh it's able to again hold some
some flood capacity and storm water uh
so that the the residents farther
Downstream in the city uh are
mitigated in terms of the effects that
they'll see during during a storm event
um so this project ran a little over
500,000 storm water only had to put in
160,000 the rest of it about 365,000 we
we were able to pay with a uh a grant
essentially uh loan forgiveness but it
ended up being a grant from the ARA
program uh back in the day so again good
use of storm water funds and we were
able to basically triple our investment
there in terms of the improvements we
got next one here East Main Street storm
sewer uh Pearl to Maple so on East Main
Street as you're coming east down from
High Street uh that hill all the way
down to Maple before this project was
was installed in 2013 there were no
storm sewers on that on that run of
Street I didn't uh I didn't look at how
long that was but um if if you were
driving through that area pre- 2013 you
would very often see a lot of storm
water buildup um down at Maple Street
there that picture is I think right in
front of the former um Rish Pharmacy um
building there but it would just uh it
would just overwhelm those storm sewers
you'd obviously Main Street a very
heavily uh driven Road uh so there would
be safe concerns with you know traffic
pedestrians and whatnot so as part of
this project we were able to put in
storm sewers starting at Pearl Street
all the way down to Maple to catch that
flow as it was coming down get it in the
storm sewer and out of the gutters to
just make things a little safer and uh
again um get that uh storm water
underground faster so it's not causing
as many issues there at Maple Street
this project was about 830,000 and storm
water funds did Cover a vast majority of
that lot threw in some funds for I think
some curve and uh sidewalk improvements
that we didn't cover the next one here
is the uh Glasco Park and Union mob
drainage improvements project this is
down in Becky's neighborhood so she's
well very familiar with this project but
um basically most of the homes there
were built in the 30s 40s 50s uh when
when they didn't have the design
standards they have today that we have
today um very little storm sewers storm
sewers that were put in were underd
designed undersized and um as a result
when you get those High intens City
short duration storms you had a lot of
storm water runoff coming off from the
hill to the west down into the ma Avenue
um Fifth Avenue 6th Avenue those areas
Broomfield and a lot of residents down
there we'd get complaints uh of um just
water water at their homes basement
streets um so this project what we did
is we built 9,300 fet of new storm sewer
also new pump station in glasow park
reconstructed glasow Park uh to mitigate
that flooding and uh again we've seen a
lot less complaints over in that area
this was again another big project 8.7
million total spent uh 7.2 of those were
from storm water funds again in this
case we were able to get a grant from
FEMA to cover that remaining $1.5
million so $15 million we did not have
to spend uh there that was able to um be
used towards making that project a
reality and then final one here is the
Cherokee Drive drainage improvements
project this project involved uh over
4,700 feet of new storm sewer the
primary driver of this project was to
reduce csos for water quality purposes
as part of our long-term control plan uh
another nice aspect though is you know
putting in the new storm sewers we able
to locate those in areas where there
were localized ponding issues on
Cherokee Drive wot Street Lawrence
Street the picture shown there is right
at the intersection of Lawrence Street
and wand dot right in front of fence
Solutions and it's a little tough to
make out but before this sewer was built
there was a bowl there no way for that
storm sewer to outlet uh and and most of
that that eastbound Lane of lawren
Street would be covered in water uh and
it's right around a curve obviously a
very dangerous situation potentially for
um drivers that are coming around that
curve so again that was a nice benefit
that we were able to locate some storm
sewers at that intersection and you know
if you're going by now uh during these
large rain events if there is any
ponding it's it's very small and very
isolated so big Improvement there uh and
again a big reduction in in flow going
to our combined sewer and keeping that
out of the stream this project was was
about 2.8 million we spent um we put
about 800,000 up front we we were able
to utilize some cdbg funding as well a
little over or a little under $100,000
and then the rest we were able to
finance through opwc and owda uh those
are loans we will have to pay back but
again we're able to do it over a longer
period of time and allow us to uh get
this project constructed earlier than we
otherwise would have
been uh so those were just the six I
wanted to highlighted there's obviously
many more with this map just kind of
wanted to show you know this these uh
show the locations where all of those 61
projects I cited earlier have been done
in the city so as you can see uh they're
happening all over the city big projects
small projects um you know all of them
having um having good effects for the
citizens for the city and uh again we've
been able to do a lot over these past 20
years with the funds we have and um this
slide here it's been cited previously
but um all those project projects
tallied up account for about over $21
million in storm water funds that have
been spent and but all those projects uh
in total the amount of funds that we
used to construct everything uh is over
60 million so some of that is Grants uh
that that are able to to cover some of
those projects I cited a couple cases
there some of those are loans where able
to defer some of those payments and then
payments sorry and then uh some of those
costs are just working with other
departments Like Water Pollution Control
Department uh the um engineering and
transportation departments during Paving
projects things like that so uh we're
very diligent in trying to um trying to
stretch our dollars as far as we can and
again have the the biggest bang for our
buck um
hopefully again I touched on it very
briefly but hopefully that gives you a
little flavor for again some of the
things we've been able to do and uh you
know as always appreciate your
consideration support and um you know in
terms of this rate increase ordinance
before you
uh and um any other questions I'm happy
to um discuss and answer any questions
from Council Members at this
time thank
you all right thank you all
thanks next up we have our INF Focus
presentation with our city police
department we're going to
dispense with turning on the
lights y yep oh you don't need it right
now we
will need it Oh I thought he said he
will no he
does it's a Monday it is a
Monday can everybody
don't need you're
good does
I'll trip over it
all right well that that's loading um
I'll give a brief introduction to what
we're doing so I know the in focus is
supposed to be Department overiew to
give you a wrap around of what we do as
an agency um unfortunately that's like
my favorite thing to do in the world so
we'd be here all night so I decided to
boil this down to our director Patrol
unit uh I can talk a little bit on what
the department looks like but more
importantly just how this fits in to our
agency um also I realize the dogs are in
here I'm the last person that you want
to pay attention to so don't feel bad at
all if you catch yourself looking back
there I do the same thing uh they're
they're definitely the stars of the show
and I'm I'm extremely happy we have them
you'll hear all about that so our agency
many of you have been on tours a couple
of you been on right um you've come to
our Events first of all very much than
for for the endorsement and and for the
support this community is definitely
different than most communities in
regards to law enforcement and how they
do us so I don't um I don't not see that
I see that every day and definitely
appreciate that also the director Patrol
unit I'm about to talk about um Austin
Brian J Chandler Chuck I I don't think I
missed anybody here um these guys have
made my job infinitely easier
they knock it out of the park and I
can't help but bring them to the
Forefront thank them for that because um
those guys that are in that unit have to
be a special breed they have to be
motivated they have to be able to think
on their feet and those are some of the
four and five best officers that we have
in the department so they should be
proud of where they're at and I'm happy
to have them there um so brief overview
as an agency we have 74 officers right
now we're authorized a strength of 79 as
you just heard we've made some
promotions um and we're not creating a
position but we're reass one of
Sergeant's positions to training
Sergeant I believe our training is is
definitely uh exponentially increased
over the years and I think you see that
as a direct result on the street I'll
start with a kind of a microcosm of what
our department looks like and how that
training and how that personnel and what
I talk about giving me the freedom to
hire good people plays out in real life
and I don't have to go back far and find
some great example I can go back to
Friday night I was in bed um someone
here in this room can attest to this I
was in bed and got a text that we had a
hostage situation and that there was a
male subject inside a residence with uh
kids inside the residence so from that
point we gave the okay for the SWAT team
to respond the SWAT team is Dispatch
they responded went to the scene while
they were waiting for the SWAT team our
officers are already engaged in talks
they're talking to this individual by
the first time one I think a single SWAT
operator um responded to the call the
female had already been released from
the house and that's through officer
communication then we get our
negotiators there and this guy that had
threat had already
allegedly
uh beat up his his significant other and
has threaten to kill cops when they got
to the scene which was what he told told
people um our slot team got there and
talked him out of the house and when we
went inside we found a rifle magazines
and surplus ammunition was C Cly 10 the
reason I say that as a microcosm is
there's several things at Play number
one we got good officers that make good
decisions they didn't run in there they
didn't make a dynamic situation worse
two their training took over I have an
officer on scene that is talking to
someone and we ended up getting a body
out of there alive unharmed an officer I
have hostage negotiators that got to the
scene and they talked the individual out
that was holding the gun was holding the
ammunition was ready to rock was Lo oted
got him out that's on him that's he's
the hostage negotiator Commander one of
his guys did that so the reason I say
all that is there's just something that
happened Friday night where it all came
together we were using Shields we were
we had less lethal out there um
unfortunately we didn't have cars in the
best shape to get out there but we had
cars to get out there so all of that
comes together and it's certainly a
great example of what this agency is
able to do there's not a call that I
don't we can respond to there really
isn't those of you that have kids in
school again those are tragic situations
we train twice a year on that we we do
praise training which is inside
organizations and inside buildings to
respond to actage year so all of that is
is covered and these guys do an amazing
job um as a department so I'll scrap all
that now and head to the the good stuff
which is the director Patrol unit a
couple years ago when we came in uh we
wanted to identify what the priorities
of the department were one of them was
to provide a healthy culture to make us
attractive for recruits because
recruiting is absolutely abysmal Across
the Nation for law enforcement uh that
was a a priority one priority two is
this direct of P troll unit and it's
more of like a Manpower multiplier how
can we identify ways to make one person
to the job of five or six this is one of
those ways so when when we ask the
community what they wanted out of this
it's typically those acute issues that
are very specific with a very specific
or residents or people that Patrol in
general has a hard time getting to so
for instance um we handle 70,000 FS per
service per year I am I going to ask a
patrol officer who's assigned to a
certain District to take care of this
one house who's selling drugs at this
time of night on this on this week night
it's just very difficult to do with the
call volume that we have um I'll also
add that per capita we're the most we're
the busiest agency in central Ohio aside
from the col police dep that's a big
deal that's a large responsibility we
have a ton of calls for service at our
agency so we had to identify how to get
to these acute problems which are very
real I don't mean to embarrass anybody
but there's several members on Council
and ex-council members that can can
attest to this uh Mr Al being one where
he's had things go on on in his area and
our director Patrol unit was able to
immediately respond to that and that's
that's just a great tool for me uh
because it gives an response to people's
needs in the community that that we
weren't able to do with
Patrol also measurables there at the end
we weren't going to start a unit if we
can't talk about the measurables if if I
can't show progress or success then
what's the point of having a project
it's it's impossible so these guys
Sergeant Sims runs the unit these guys
measure their response so not only are
we going to respond to a complaint in Mr
Able's als's neighborhood we're also
going to be able to give him information
that we came there
37 times in the last week we observed
for over 14 hours worth of activity and
we made this many arrests or this many
traffic stops or what haveed that goes
all the way from traffic up to narcotics
you're going to see some pretty
astonishing numbers just from this unit
alone they aren't Department wi numbers
they just this unit alone this shows you
their
capabilities one cave off to this we
wanted to Ru the K9 into this unit U
that is something that's just been a
long time coming for this area trust you
me drug traffickers in this area knew we
did not have K they knew it um as as an
officer working through that that can be
a frustrating thing they knew it didn't
exist they knew we didn't have that
capability now we do you're going to see
some some major results from that aside
from that officer safety which you'll
also see we'll have a video clip just
again on microcosm of what these dogs
can do and what our handers did do next
you don't
mind um to give you an idea this
director Patrol unit what it is it's
five officers well four now technically
we just handed a promotion to one but
it's five officers three Kines and two
officers that do not have a k9 they just
respond directly to these to these uh
acute
needs when we were initially planning
this unit we were trying to figure out
how to get it up and run it do we use
volunteers do we pull resources from
uniform controls do we use SWAT guys uh
on their days off that we use their
officers Etc and I would say we da about
all of that and nothing really worked
for us uh up until we just pulled the
trigger and said that's it we're
assigning going of this and that was our
first K9 Officer Austin Pierce as as we
saw the success from that we knew we had
to build on it it was an impossibility
just to sit on our hands at that point
so um after Austin won the inaugural job
of being our director TR officer uh we
just started growing that unit and I'll
never look back this has been the most
valuable we at the PD um for a long time
in my opinion so what you're looking at
there is problem like this is typical
problem analysis when something comes in
so all of you know you'll have a
complaint or observation from your
constituents before we had the director
Patrol unit we did a pretty good job of
of noting complaints that's we're pretty
good at that we can find complaints uh
pretty easily we were able to prioritize
it before um we knew what the priority
of of some neighborhood issues or
Community issues were
where we did not do so well was
dedicating resources to it we either
didn't have them or didn't dedicate them
correctly um and we can own that and
then measuring responses zero zil we we
had we relied basically on a cad system
to measure results um or some Excel
spreadsheet somewhere um and that just
wasn't good enough when people ask
questions I can confidently say after
after the start of this unit uh and
mostly due to Sergeant Sims and and his
crew after the start of it we knock each
of those out of the park um if you ever
are interested I can I can show you the
Case Files of how we've respond to the
community complaints things that we've
nipped in the bud and wrapped up and
it's awesome because when we respond to
one now you get an officer showing up at
your door you get to talk to an officer
when we respond to one now you get a
police presence if there's an actual
problem there you're going to see cops
in your neighborhood and if there's a
problem when arrest people take to jail
that's an absolute fact and we can show
you those we can show you those
chuck if you want to hit the next U
slide this is our uh unit as it exists
other than officer cook he was just
promoted today but this unit runs in our
special services division which includes
Major Crimes unit detective Bureau
Community Services dare and now directed
Patrol unit Lieutenant Underwood is the
commander of that unit as of today and
Sergeant Sims has been running this
since its Inception um and he's
primarily responsible for why it is it
today we have officers up there officer
Pierce dogado cook who promoted Malone
and evko and then we call them our
superheroes a Megan Becky and Barry and
these things have been Lifesavers
literal Lifesavers um when I say that we
have somebody bail from a stop and take
off and hide in between houses if you
don't have a dog you're guessing at that
point you're guessing what corner of
that person's around you're going to see
in video today that they take a lot of
the guest work out and it makes
everybody saf um and we're very happy
for that Chuck you want hit the next
slide this is just some quick
photographs of of what we do and who we
partner with uh really just feel good
stuff we don't need to look at that or
waste any L time with it but just this
this unit's out all over uh the train
all the time U and they do a really good
job of it here's just some stats and
numbers I know these can be hard to read
but I want to uh illustrate something
for you so the top row
uh the Lancaster dpu stats that's just
for 2024 that's not the units Inception
um so that's just up to this point so
far 332 traffic stops 156 citations and
just so you know on citations that's not
oh you don't have a registration sticker
that is literally an accident causing
violation so that is ramped our numbers
up there as well 139 K9 deployments 115
warrants serve 75 Mr charges 2 felony
charges 205 uh assistant on patrol calls
meaning they back Patrol up 69 cases or
instances of assisting the major crimes
unit 15 guns off the street and 46 calls
serviced meaning that's 46 calls that
our Patrol
officers um I'm sorry that's assisted
the 205 calls that's 205 times an
officer did not have to handle the call
out on the street meaning they were
freed up to do proactive activity the
other three numbers are pretty
demonstrative of what I'm saying about
these dogs and really not just these
dogs the officers because I say this all
the time you can go out and get the best
dog in the world it's worth absolutely
nothing if you don't have the right hand
if you don't have the right Officer that
dog is worth nothing if the officer's
not training the dog's worth nothing um
a lot of what you see when it comes to
you know worst case scenarios with dogs
well probably argue the training wasn't
there I'd probably argue the structure
wasn't there I'd probably argue the
department wasn't ready to have a dog at
that point um these dogs are phenomenal
these three guys are phenomenal Jay
you're phenomenal as well but they're
not interested in you you don't have a
dog
um but this is just indicative of of
what they do so for instance the 28 gr
of fentanyl so far 690 G of
methamphetamine SE 27 G of cocaine let
me give you a quick rundown of what that
means
so this on theide here
um this is about 10 GRS of meth or crack
would you guys
agree about 10 grams of meth or crack
okay fentanyl which we all know is
taking over our city has taken over
every city there's not a city in the
world that has not the F some are just
more well equipped to hide it than
others some have more resources than
others uh to make it you know quieter
quieter of the problem but everybody
deals with it 10 G here fentanyl to kill
you is about 2 milligrams right so we're
talking 2,000 times smaller than a gram
so in order to kill anyone in this
room and nobody's on TV is going to be
able to see this but I need something
about 100 times smaller than
that right there that's that's B and
that will kill you and 26 28 I can't
even read it 26 28 gr of fentanyl have
been taken off the street you can't
measure that there's nothing that I can
do to show how valuable that is I can't
show you how many lives we're saved
that's just impossible but the efficacy
of this unit is is above every standard
that I would be and again this is just
this year's numb so far so these guys do
a really good job um one thing I always
say if you want an opinion on the police
department how we're doing I'm the last
person to ask you should ask an officer
you should ask one of the people that's
working getting out shagg and calls in
black and white those are the people
that that you need to ask about how the
Department's doing and and you know what
progress we made Etc because I'm just
going to get up here and and blow a
bunch of hot air right so Austin uh our
dpu officer and the Handler for Omega is
going to go over the dog portion of it
and give you more uh more ground
level I'm also uh up at kega for a year
now so we've been going for a year back
to drugs so this is myself and officer
Chandler we just got this stop on
Saturday um
this was a cold kind of cold stop we got
a call about felony warrant the guy um
was one for bonus assault which
obviously becomes a dog call because of
the use of for behind that we can offer
and keep the patrol guys safe so just a
month prior to this he went after his
girlfriend and another person went
machete so we we're on high alert and so
we uh myself off TR pull up beside his
car kind of on stop on him
and once we get in cffs we run the dogs
on the vehicle they alert and we end up
getting 26 gram of cocaine that was
right off the brick which that means
whoever's de with kind Big Time
plus7 pills which the street value of
that over $8,000 alone they had $438 on
on them as well so that's just what
Saturday so the functions which
obviously you guys can tell all three of
our dogs are totally different than each
other but they all uh all three are on
narcotics so they're training to detect
cocaine heroin me and their derivatives
so fentanyl is a derivative parin so
they'll detect that and then anything
cut like crack it be from cocaine uh
tracking uh they do uh ground
disturbance and air sense so ground
disturbance is basically your shoes
relieving some type of that's not
organic to the ground surface so they're
just getting anything that's not organic
to that area and then air sending we
have adrenaline going through our bodies
or fear hormones so anytime we're
tracking like a suspect that fled from
us it's a lot easier than the missing
held early person that we also can track
but missing out early person doesn't
know that they're missing or the
autistic kit that we've done few tracks
for um that goes the same with article
searches out like a robbery or anything
uh someone drops like it's a b in in the
field these dos can pick up the scent
just from the air that because it's not
organic now if it's been sent for a week
we're going to struggle a little bit but
the dogs are all on that apprehension
all three of these dogs are light dogs
but they're not monsters anybody can go
and pet anyone these dogs even right
after a fight it's not emotional to them
at all it's just a job it's a giant
truee toy so you see the balls that
they're all holding let go that ball
just as well as the will of person just
no emotion to them then The Obedience um
what they're certified on the state what
we consider obedience is a little
different so the
state wants them to stay by our side
just like show dog uh we work a lot of
obedience and drive so we get the dogs
elevated um just like they would on
building search or going after suspect
and we still want them to listen our
Command so we'll send them on each other
recall send them Recon uh send them down
so they're still maintain all that Focus
even though their emotions are super
high in their prey drive because every
one of these dogs have a high prey drive
but they're so list in our Command so we
really focus on
that so this is going to be a Malone and
meck's track this
is just picture perfect we had a known
one Patrol units uh stops a known
motorcycle gang member that's weapons F
from a traffic stop I think Malone gets
there in just a couple
minutes five
minutes uh immediately from the vehicle
he's already working his knows but just
like uh any time we leave the house we
got to use R because he has been in the
cruiser but his nose is still
working he's almost done he's in the
rest
all right so now now he's working you
can hear the the bread that's his mouth
open he's tasting human odor right now
so he's using his
nose and he's going to work inside a s
so just like a triangle from the source
of the odor the point being where the
human is or was but the wind's
constantly blowing human odor so he's
going to work the air to the ground and
he'll go
outside and he's going to realize
there's no over there he's going to look
back to the line of stradle which is
where um this m ran
to so once again he's working uh he's
probably on a 15ot lead I haven't got to
watch this
video so he the office he's Downing him
and refocusing so just making sure the
dogs confirming what what's going on he
just picked up a foot
FR so all the human odor flowing along
that bench right now
and you can hear him really smelling so
you know he's kind of getting closer
human is pretty
fresh you're
good so right here when he locks up
that's what we call danger close that
tells us that he's somewhere that our
Patrol unit seem to be on the
lookout so he just worked the right side
of con and now he's at the end of the
left side and he knows the guy is close
he just hasn't had a bar foot on him yet
until this
week and this mouse right there and
inside the vehicle he left a loaded gun
he's not supposed to possess the gun
along with
mask so that just like Chief said we're
gessing when we're on patrol before
these dos we all went around the blind
corner and had no idea what was going on
um and this is just one of many
situations that a week later track
another person that Bel from the county
so we operate with the county lot too
and
um all all three dogs are we kind of
focus on tracking a lot the dope is
amazing the dogs are always going to dop
on or they're always going to BU SM dope
but the tracking just the safety aspect
behind it and the ability to find the
missing
uh at the same time is just tremendous
for
us other any questions with the
dogs I appreciate everybody's here one
thing I just want to add to that
actually just kind of on is you saw in
the video the ability for us to find
that dog um we've all been on calls
where we don't have a dog in that
situation run into somebody or you just
don't find it and that's where I say the
positives for having these are it's the
the patol officers it's a tool now that
I don't think they can go without now
that they've seen how safe it keeps them
and and the results that we get out of
it and honestly um like Austin said
Priority One is saving life so missing
persons and safety that's definitely
Priority One but I'll tell you the
impact that's made on the
um Sergeant Sims goes to the major
crimes unit meetings every Monday
morning chuck would you say that this
area knows that we have dogs yeah it's
uh through their sources and informs and
different things there's been a lot of
talk of we're not going to come down
lanter come up and meet us at road if
they want to get it because we're not
going to make the trip Lan's too much
going on so that's a huge success
believe it or not it doesn't stop it I'm
not going to lie and say it stops I'm
telling you that's a huge success that
people are a little bit nervous come on
down south a little further there course
and I'll just end on I want to emphasize
that I know we've only talked about
direct patroling I'd love to have you
guys for eight hours so I can talk about
everybody uh but these four guys here
and the five really that we had um
they're awesome I mean I can't say
enough about them these officers you
have to put the right people in those
positions it has to be somebody you can
turn your back on and know that they're
going to do the right thing and these
guys kill it they are awesome so that's
all we had if you have questions for me
can we see the other two dogs that we
didn't get to see all the dogs just the
one
okay no we're going to keep them around
after
meeting and you can walk up to any of
them they're all very very
well competitors so they look at each
other and see bigger than the other so
they'll be around
after the meeting any questions at all
about that unit just a huge thank
you thank you guys thank you guys wow we
can't do this without without the
ability on the
back so so Chief you referenced the fact
that you're going to have a training
Sergeant position correct can you tell
me what can you explain and elaborate
what that is yeah so um it's not
something that's a novel idea from the
ler Police Department i' love to credit
for it it's a very very very common uh
position in law enforcement in a law
enforcement agency espec especially a
midsize or upper level agency uh what
they do is number one it's an audit
Trail for all the training in your
department so when you look on TV and
you see some bad situation and then they
do a followup interview like they
haven't trained on this in 30 years or
they haven't been staying compliant with
this that's that's a training issue
that's that's a management issue where
you've not done a good job
and what your officers need so the main
focus will be the ability to have kind
of a clearing house for all the training
of the agency what we really like about
it however is we do a heck of a lot of
training um we do inservice trainings
multiple times a year we do roll call
trainings um if if at the end of the
shift the shift isn't that busy they'll
do training at the end of the shift we
try to do as much as we can now we're
very we don't have any space to train so
we just use rooms that we have but that
training Sergeant will be able to
coordinate the inservice training the
external training um he'll be able to
look at our roster and see where certain
officers lack in training so if you've
done all tactics all tactics all tactics
and you're on patrol they'll be able to
identify you need more Communications
you need more interview you need more
interrogation um also some of the the
hot button topics around the world I
won't get too social with this but some
of the the hot button uh pie need
included in your in your agency that
Sergeant will know what those are and
that Sergeant will be able to implement
them within the agency as well so we are
we're in line with with everyone else so
really it's just a Central Area a
central person for our training to be
coordinated with throughout the
department because right now it's just
shift to shift to shift officer to
officer to officer okay do you view it
as a risk management tool I know that
liability insurance especially for law
enforcements becoming exponentially more
expensive well this going to help reduce
that in the future do you think I can't
speak to whether it will R reduce our
premium or whe whether it will increase
decrease coverage that that'll be up to
the insurers I can tell you this as
police chief I'll be able to confidently
get in front of you and say every single
one of my officers is trained the way
they should be I would not be put in a
position where if we have to take
someone's life that I'm up here
explaining to you why the officer
doesn't have the right training that I
can guarantee you as far as a
in redu or whatever I hope so but I
don't think anybody can read the minds
of an insurance company however I just I
would hope that in that position that
would be something that's kept in mind
from a risk management stand again it's
a priority one because that's going to
look around and we already hit all the
requirements don't get me wrong the
agency is very very good well Tred
agency we're going to check every box we
do the Ohio collaborative every year
that'll be fine I'm talking more about
those applicable trainings that may not
be requirements but they're much more
needed than say some State mandated
requirement that the state doesn't you
need this training Sergeant will be able
to throw in appable real world training
that helps our officer show up to a
hostage call and be able to get the
woman out
safely any further questions from
Council Members I know council member
teners biting chomping at the bit see
the
dogs any other
questions all right
thank you very much thank you gentlemen
we appreciate
it we going to now move back to the
agenda with petitions and memorials
there are none Now we move on to the
permission of Voters and taxpayers to
address council is there anybody here
this evening who would like to address
council at this
time seeing none we thank you for coming
reports of standing committees code and
zoning committee minutes dated April 8th
2024 submitted by Mr aers law committee
minutes and amended minutes dated May
6th 2024 submitted by Mr niser finance
committee minutes dated May 6 2024
submitted by Mr
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
motion to receive and file the reports
of standing committees second we have a
motion and second to receive and file
the reports of standing committees all
those in favor please say I I all those
oppos same sign reports of special
committees there are none no public
hearing this evening we're going to move
on to reading of resolutions uh with the
third reading of temporary resolution
5624 a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the three M Street
Improvement Levy fund 2000009 coming out
of Finance sponsored by Mr wolfinger
second by Mr Al council member wolfinger
Mr President I would like to make a
motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record resolution
number
56-24
second council member wolfinger
discussion
um not really it's uh uh dealing with a
three M Levy and correcting the
uh the numbers okay I have no further
discussion from any council members
please call follow Mr aers yes Mr ALS
yes Mr bisek yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr niser yes Mr skover yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes
motion to pass uh temporary resolution
5624 passes 10 to Z we'll now move on to
the second reading of resolutions with
temporary resolution
5724 a resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter into a contract with a
Fairfield County General Health District
for Public Health Services coming out of
Finance sponsored by Mr wolfinger
seconded by Mr alers council member
wolfinger second of three readings
second of three readings on temporary
resolution
5724 temporary resolution
5824 a resolution to increase receipts
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and amend the certificate of
Appropriations with the county auditor
in the timbertop Tiff fund
2060 coming out of Finance sponsored by
Mr wolfinger seconded by Mr Al council
member wolfinger second of three
readings second of three readings on
temporary resolution
5824 temporary resolution
5924 a resolution approving and
authorizing the mayor to submit to the
US Department of Housing and Urban
Development Langster fiscal year 2024
Community Development block grant annual
action plan and statement of objectives
coming out of Economic Development
sponsored by Mrs hoop seconded by Mr
haiser council member hoop second of
three readings second of three readings
on temporary resolution
5924 we now move on to the first reading
of resolutions with temporary resolution
6124 a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the police and fire
Levy fund 2047 coming out of safety
sponsored by Mr bisj and seconded by
Miss tener council member bisj thank you
Mr President this is first of three
readings first of three readings on
temporary resolution 61
124 temporary resolution
6224 a resolution to change the special
Revenue fund 206 Timber Top Tiff to a
capital projects fund
3060 coming out of Finance sponsored by
Mr wolfinger wolfinger seconded by Mr
alss council member wol finger thank you
Mr President I would like to make a
motion that Council suspends it suspends
its rules and waves the second and third
readings of temporary resolution 62-24
second we have a motion in a second to
suspend the rules and wave the second
and third readings of temporary
resolution
6224 uh discussion uh this is merely a
housekeeping item to amend the fund
numbers from 2060 to
3060 any further
discussion hearing none please call the
role Mr aers yes Mr ALS Mr bisek yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr niser yes yes
Mr skover yes Miss steer yes Mr Wing yes
Mr wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and wave the second and third
reading of temporary resolution 6224
passes 10 to Z council member wolfinger
thank you Mr President I would like to
make a motion that Council pass and
gross and Inter on the written record
temporary resolution
6224 second we have a motion the second
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution 6224
council member wolfinger any further
discussion no sir hearing none any
additional please call the r Mr aers yes
Mr ALS Mr bisek yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr niser yes Mr skover yes
Miss Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution 6224
passes 10 to zero are there any further
resolutions for consideration this
evening
hearing none we'll move on to the
reading of ordinances uh we have no
third readings uh move to the second
reading of temporary ordinance
1524 an ordinance to amend section
9184 B of the codified ordinances of the
city of Lancaster entitled user rates
and charges coming out of water water
pollution control sponsored by Mr Wing
seconded by Mrs tener council member
Wing second of three readings please
second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 15
1824 we now move on to First reading
with temporary ordinance
1824 an ordinance to authorize the mayor
to enter into an agreement to purchase
1590 East Main Street approximately 1.0
plus or minus Acres of real of real
property further identified as Fairfield
County auditor parcel number 0535
80610 for an amount not to exceed
$250,000 and to declare an emergency
coming out of safety sponsored by Mr
bisek seconded by Mr aers council member
bisj thank you Mr President this is the
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
1824 temporary ordinance
1924 an ordinance to repeal and rep and
replace Lancaster codified ordinance
part seven business Regulation Code
chapter 709 cultivation processing or
dispensing of medical marijuana or the
codified
ordinances of the city of Lancaster
coming out of law sponsored by Mr niser
by Mr wolfinger council member niser yes
thank you Mr President this is the first
of three readings first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
1924 we have no tabled legislation this
evening any unfinished
business any new business at this
time yes Mr President yes Mr Mayor so I
forwarded a resume for a u a nomination
for the
Fairfield County Regional Planning
Commission and I would like to ask
Council to consider that tonight um Amy
Cohen has agreed to accept the position
um I will tell you let me start this
conversation with saying it is very
difficult to find someone willing to
take their time and volunteer to serve
on these commissions I sent an email to
council multiple times asking for any
input you might have I've received no
recommendation from any anyone here
so we've gotten together with several
people and ask for names and uh I look
at uh this position and I would say Amy
Cohen is a perfect candidate for this
position she's involved in our community
has been involved in her community for
many years uh her resume tells you how
active she is and how she likes to
contribute uh she's currently uh on the
festival board she's uh worked for fair
for Medical Center fairfeld homes
Midwest benefits I mean it's just an
impressive resume and I think she's a
perfect
fit we have several seats on the
Fairfield County Regional Planning
Commission we still have vacancies
Beyond this so I'm asking Council to
consider Amy to be appointed to this
position and uh if you have any
questions um feel free to ask okay does
anybody have any questions for the mayor
on the appointment uh related to miss
Cohen to the regional planning commit
I yes council member wol I would just
like to add I've known Amy but more
importantly her dad was a very close
friend clonial Heights Furniture uh his
mom it's a quality family good people
okay thank you I will just note that the
regional Planning Commission upon which
I also serve um it uh meets in the
evening it's very hard to get people to
come to those meetings I do believe we
do have um one of the members here as
well um and so Amanda is serving um
representing the city of Lancaster so um
if you think of anybody or know of
anybody who would be willing to serve
please get those names to the mayor or
the service safety director um because
there are vacancies so the more people
we have the more likely we'll have
Quorum and be able to conduct business
so um at this time I would take a motion
to appoint Miss Cohen to the uh Regional
Planning Commission so move Mr President
council member bisj do we have a second
second council member Wing um can we
have R call please yes Mr aers yes Mr
ALS yes Mr bisek yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr niser yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger
yes thank you um Miss Cohen uh is
appointed thank you also your
notification also let me follow up with
I do intend uh several council members
have expressed to me that would they
would like to meet these candidates in
Mr Cohen's
defense I failed to invite her to
tonight's meeting uh the vacancy exists
and I'd like to fill it but as we move
forward whenever possible any candidate
I'm bringing to recommend to you I'm
going to bring them forward and have
them introduce themselves and get you
the ability to actually meet them uh
that's my plan going forward and I think
we've seen that already with the tree
commission and a couple other
appointments we appreciate that Mr Mayor
um and also as i' I've mentioned you
know um we would welcome council members
uh to to provide candidates and I do
believe that council member aers um and
council member tener are going to be
working together for any Council
appointments uh to help screen
candidates and bring candidates forth is
that
correct yeah okay I know that it was
discussed at a previous
okay okay thank you um any U okay we'll
move on any other new
business announcement of schedule
meetings next regular sessions of
council June 10th at 6:30 p.m. June 24th
at 6:30
p.m. upcoming special meetings code and
Zoning June 21st at 8:00 a.m. City Hall
1897 conference room upcoming committee
meetings for the next 30 days water
water pollution control May 24th at 7:30
a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room
service June 7th at 8:00 a.m. City Hall
1897 conference room safety June 7th at
9:00 a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room
Finance June 10th at 600 p.m. ccil
Chambers Cod and Zoning June 10th at
8:00 a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room
Public Works June 14th at 7:30 a.m. City
Hall 1897 conference room administrative
Services June 16th
that's apologies that's an error June
19th at 8: a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room finan June 24th at 6 PM
Council council chambers okay thank you
um we can move on with the reading of
bills mnco for the publication of
legislation
$12.19 and Vista Print
$34.88 for business cards Mr President
I'd like to make a motion to pay the
bills second we have a motion and second
to pay the bills all those in favor
please say I I all those oppos same
sign we have no need for an executive
session I'd entertain a motion to
adjourn Mr President I'll will make that
motion that we adjourn second the motion
second to adjourn all those in favor
please say I I thank you everybody for
coming U and have a good evening please
remember to stay and sign your
legislation where's
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home en
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
0652 stop in and see us at either of our
two locations 405 North Columbus Street
in Lancaster and 207 South Main Street
in Baltimore respect for tradition
regard for
change hi this is Jolan Pew with Big
Brothers Big Sisters of South Eastern
Ohio for well over 100 years Big
Brothers Big Sisters have operated under
the belief that every child can succeed
and thrive in life this month we have
once again been chosen as the recipient
of the Buckeye cares program that means
that Buckeye cares will make a generous
donation with every vehicle they sell in
the month of May thank you Buckeye for
helping out our kids and support of your
local
community for